And I think we're on April the 6th, 1922, is that right?
Yes.
Okay.
So the introduction says, "The effects of the acts on in the divine will, in the divine
will, the soul, places herself at the level of the Creator."
That's the bit you underline, okay.
As I was in my usual state, my sweet Jesus carried me outside of myself and showed me
masses of people crying, homeless, prey to the greatest desolation, towns collapsed, streets
deserted and uninhabitable.
That makes me ask the question, "Is she looking at Hiroshima or Nagasaki?"
Okay.
Because the Lord always shows the prophets something ahead of time, so that the intercession and
the reparation is done for the people who had no time, because those people died in seconds,
they had absolutely no time.
And the way the Lord works out is that they have all been prayed for and reparation has
all been done for them, which shows you the extraordinary mercy of God, while an unbeliever
looking at it thinks this is a hopeless situation, in fact, it's all prepared for.
One could see nothing but heaps of stones and rubble.
Only one point remained untouched by the scourge.
That's what makes me say Nagasaki or Hiroshima, because of the, remember the Jesuit communities
and the community of Mactimilian Colby, they were, both of them separately in different
places were the only thing left standing.
That's why it makes me decide on that.
Otherwise, you could say, "Well, maybe she's seen Dresden in Germany at the Second World
War, but it doesn't seem to me to be that.
My God fought pain to see these things and live.
I looked at my sweet Jesus and he didn't aim to look at me.
Rather, he cried bitterly and with a voice broken by crying, he said, "My daughter, man
has forgotten heaven for the earth."
It's not interesting.
We're back at that point again, aren't we?
It is justice that what is earth be taken away from him and that he go wandering, unable
to find shelter, so that he remain that heaven exists.
There's another purpose for chastisement, which is quite clear to try and make them understand
that heaven exists and heaven is the most important address that you should have.
Man has forgotten the soul for the body, and it's the second thing again, so the body
has to suffer.
It's a wonderful explanation of chastisement this.
So everything is for the body, pleasure, comfort, sumptuousness, luxury, and the like.
The soul is starving, deprived of everything, and in many it is dead, as if they didn't
have it.
Now it is justice that their bodies be deprived so that they may remember that they have a
soul.
See, the logic is very interesting there.
How hard man is, his hardness forces me to strike him more.
Who knows whether he might soften under the blows, okay?
So for hardness of heart, look up Revelation 16, 9, Revelation 16, 9, 11, and 21.
Now in Revelation 16, 9, 11, and 21, you're told that at the great chastisement that the
people cursed God, and you're told three times, that's the 9, 11, and 21, that instead
of softening they actually cursed God for the chastisement.
So Louisa said, "I felt my heart being tortured," and he said, "You suffer very much in seeing
the world as if it wanted to roll, and water and fire spilling out of their boundaries."
So if the earth wanted to roll, you mean spin?
She wouldn't have used the term spin.
And water and fire spilling out of their boundaries.
We're living at the stage where water and fire spill out of their boundaries, okay, hurling
themselves at man.
So there's the nature rebelling against man, "Therefore let us withdraw together into
your bed, and let us pray together for the destiny of man.
In my will I will feel your heart beating over the entire face of the earth, giving me
a heartbeat for all, a word that says love.
And as I strike the creatures, your heartbeat will place itself in the way so that the blows
will be less hard, and upon touching them may bring the bam of my love and of yours."
So that amazing statement, okay.
So even in the chastisement itself, Louisa is asked to participate so that people even
experiencing the chastisement will somehow know, maybe in the depths of their being,
that the God of love is actually touching them to try and bring some kind of spiritual
healing.
Louisa remained all afflicted, and she said, "More so since, as we withdrew, my sweet Jesus
hid in my interior but so deep, that he almost would not let himself be felt any more.
What pain, what torment, the thought of the scourge has terrorized me, and his privations
gave me mortal pains."
Now in this state, this is very important, she has described total agony here, in this
state, "I tried to fuse myself in the holy will of God."
Now to me that's a great consolation because it's saying that there are times when it's
going to be difficult for you to do it.
And I said, "My love in your will, what is yours, is mine."
You see, there's that wonderful statement, okay.
All created things are mine, the sun is mine, and I give it to you in return.
So that all the light and the heat of the sun, each drop of its light and heat may tell you
that I love you, I adore you, I bless you, I praise you for all the lovely little round.
The stars are mine, and in every flickering of the stars, I seal my, I love you, infinite
and immense for all.
The plants and the flowers and the water, the fire and the air are mine, and I give them
to you in return, that all of them may say to you in the name of all.
I love you with that same eternal love with which you created us."
So there's a very nice little round there, if you're ever in a hurry, because it says
it all in a few sentences.
But if I wanted to say everything, it would be too long, she's got to stop saying that
particular sentence.
Then Jesus moving in my interior told me, "My daughter, how beautiful are the prayers
and the acts done in my will, how the creature is transformed in God, the Creator himself,
and gives him in return for what he has given to her.
I created everything for man and I gave everything to him as gift, that's Colossians 1, 15-17,
Colossians 1, 15-17.
In my will, the creature rises up to her God and Creator and finds him in the act in which
he created all things to give them to her as gift.
And trembling before the multiplicity of so many gifts, not having within herself the
creative power to create as many things for as many as she has received, she offers him
his own things to requite him in love.
I love that expression, offering him his own things.
That's like the child coming in from the garden and they've taken your favorite rose
and they haven't even plucked it properly and they hand it to you with love and it's very
important to only look at the love, isn't it?
If you look at anything else you might have a problem, at least if you were me.
I gave you the sun, I gave you stars, flowers, water, fire, air, to give you love, everything
is to give you love.
And you are grateful, you accepted them and putting my love in circulation, you gave me
love in return for them.
That's a wonderful explanation of what rounds are.
Okay, so if you ever just want to do a short little summary on rounds, there you have it.
The round 11 steps to it.
The notes of my love resounded again over all created things and with one voice you gave
me the love which I made flow over the whole of creation.
Now in my will the soul places herself at the level of her creator and in his own will
she receives and she gives.
There you are on a divine level.
It's easy to read but to try and take it in is another matter, okay?
Oh what a contest between the creature and the creator happens.
If all could see it they would remain stupefied at seeing that in my will the soul becomes
a little God, small G. Now if you read the book I gave you or got you to read last year
or the year before you become a little Elohim because that's the Hebrew word, okay?
But everything by virtue of the power of my will.
So I want to give you Sam 8, Lord what is man that you would even consider him and yet
you made him a little less than a God crowning him with glory and honor.
That's what you're being told here.
Also Sam 82 verse 6 I said you are God's all of you sons of the most high.
Now God's in the plural is Elohim with the small E and sons of the most high are the
same thing, okay?
But sons of the most high also represent the angels, okay?
So you have an expression there with actual multiple meaning in its original.
So I think that's a wonderful gentle way to be able to introduce rounds to people.
So April the 8th 1922 the most holy trinity concurring in the creation of man, the sorrow
of Jesus and seeing the will, the intelligence and the memory of man deformed.
So there's the three great powers of the soul for which he took the three crownings wasn't
it?
So Louisa said finding myself in my usual state I was thinking about the sorrow that
my sweet Jesus suffered in the garden of Gethsemane when all of our sins presented themselves
before his sanctity and Jesus all afflicted told me in my interior.
What told me in my interior is an interior locution, okay?
My daughter, my sorrow was great and incomprehensible to the created mind because he's told us
that his sorrow is at a level that we don't understand, especially when I saw the human
intelligence deformed.
Look at this, the beautiful image of myself which I reproduced in it was no longer beautiful
but it was horrid and ugly.
So if people ask you where is the image of God in us Jesus says it's in your intelligence.
Is that something?
Let's look at it again especially when I saw the human intelligence deformed that beautiful
image of myself which I reproduced and it was no longer beautiful ugly but it was ugly
and it was horrid, okay.
So now he's going to take that separately and talk about it.
So in the next paragraph we're going to have the will and the following one, the intellect
and then the following, the memories, we're going to take them one after the other.
So with regard to the will, everything's in the will.
I endowed man with will, intellect and memory, the three gate powers.
In the first Sean my celestial father, so I have father in the margin for myself, it
is in the first Sean my celestial father who as primary act communicated his power, his
sanctity and his height through which he elevated the human will.
So you can see why the whole of the Old Testament is between God the father and his people trying
to get his people to agree intellectually to doing his will.
I just want to give it to you from this angle because you know that the battle was between
the human will and the divine will anyway but it's God the father, the human will.
So he elevated the human will investing it with his own sanctity, power and nobility,
leaving all currents between himself and the human will open so that it might be enriched
more and more with the treasures of my divinity.
So that was actually the reality in innocent Adam before the fall.
Between the human will and the divine there was neither yours nor mine, you've just heard
Louisa saying everything that yours is mine.
But everything was in common with mutual accord and you're going to hear all of this with
regard to Adam as he when he speaks about Adam.
Adam was our image, our own thing, so look at this, he veiled us.
He veiled us the image of God was in the heart of man, okay.
So if you see man, male or female, living at the level that they should be living at
you should be able to see God in that person but we do see them, don't we, because we often
say such and such a person is very Christ like, you know, so you're actually saying
that you recognize a presence.
Even if people are very far from the reality that we're talking about, they can somehow
pick it up quicker than someone who is closer to you in trying to live it.
I remember being quite shocked at one stage many years ago, a principal of a school not
in this country said to me, I need you to speak to these children and I said, why?
He said they need to feel the impact of your presence.
I said, what are you talking about?
I thought he was talking about, do you know what I mean?
But then I discovered he had been a Catholic, he was no longer a Catholic and all of a sudden
from the distance that he was at, he could see something that you and I couldn't say.
Does that make sense?
People in the new age can perceive what they call an aura and that they don't recognize
that they're looking at the presence of God in you.
They're calling it by a wrong name, do you know what I mean?
But they do actually perceive it, okay?
But if we're talking to each other, we don't see it because we're all too close to each
other, so man veiled the blessed Trinity, I think that's fantastic, just as the host
veils the divine presence, okay?
So you can see a hint about consecrated hosts here, can't you?
Our life was to be his and therefore as primary act, he constituted his will free and independent
as we were to be truly like God, we had to be free and independent, just as the will
of my celestial father was as primary act.
But how much has this will disfigured itself, free as it was, it rendered itself the slave
of the most vile passions.
It is the will, it is the will that is the beginning of all the evils of man.
So you will realize why I pointed out all the time from the very beginning that Jesus
would say, don't put your will into it, don't put your will into it.
The will is the origin of everything.
And so it can no longer be recognized how it decayed from its nobility, it is disgusting
to look at, okay?
Now we can't see this at all from where we're at.
So the next paragraph then is the intellect and the son, the will, the father, the intellect,
the son and the memory, the Holy Spirit.
So this is where we're going with this.
So in the second act, I, the son of God, concurred with the endowing man with intellect, communicating
to him my wisdom and knowledge of all things.
Now Genesis chapter two tells us in the most childlike language that Adam had knowledge
of all things, okay?
So notice that if we are recovered or recovering in our relationship with God, wisdom and knowledge
have got to turn up and wisdom is the first one.
Is that okay?
Wisdom understanding, counsel, fortitude, knowledge, piety and the fear of the Lord.
But the Lord in these writings always puts wisdom and knowledge together so that by knowing
them, he might enjoy them and delight in what is good, one Thessalonians 5, 21, delighting
in what is good.
But alas, what a bilge of vices is the intellect, the intelligence of the creature.
He has used his knowledge to deny his Creator.
And unfortunately, that particular problem can manifest itself in religious people quicker
than anybody else, and it's very well illustrated and described in Pharisees in the Gospel.
They were the very ones who were completely against the truth and the grace that was being
offered to them.
So in the next paragraph, then it's memory and it's the Holy Spirit.
Then as third act, the Holy Spirit concurred by endowing him with memory so that in remembering
so many benefits, he might be in continuous currents of love, in continuous relations.
Love was to crown him, embrace him and permeate all his life.
That's Ephesians 3, 16 to 21, founded in love, built on love, grow in love, reach the
fullness of love.
But how saddened the eternal love remains.
So actually, just looking at that and standing back from it just very slightly, you'll see
that the blessed trinity, each of the persons of the blessed trinity, is extremely sad
by the condition of man and how they all had to concur in letting Jesus suffer interiorly
to try and open all of these channels up again.
This memory remembers pleasures, riches and remembers even to sin, while the sacrosanct
trinity is cast out of the gifts which it gave to its creatures.
My sorrow was indescribable at seeing the deformity of the three powers of man.
We had formed our royal palace in him.
So now you know where the royal palace is in the intellect, memory and will.
This is what's lovely about this, I look at these writings as a huge big jigsaw puzzle
and there's another little piece and there's another little piece and I feel the same in
finding the pieces here as I do it with the jigsaw puzzle.
There's the piece I've been looking at for ages, I've been looking for it.
So we had formed our royal palace in him and we had cast us out.
Now there's a terrible statement in Matthew 723, away from me you evil men, but what's
happening and has happened in the world that we're living in is that God has been cast
out.
He's been cast out of the church in many instances.
He has been cast out of society.
So not only has he not got his palace to live in in each individual, but he's been cast
out even of society itself, well chastisement has to follow that, absolutely has to, sheer
logic would tell you that.
So April the 12th, 1922, sin breaks the current of love.
That's a bit like saying that the connection that I need to get my phone or whatever it
is working has been broken, it's been snapped and it opens a current of justice and it's
up to ourselves which one we're going to be in.
Now before we even read it, I just want to remind you of someone I would have said to
you many times and that is if you look at my two hands as the two extremes of a relationship
that a child has with its parents.
One is justice for doing things wrong and the other is all affirmation and love for doing
things right.
So if the child is open to learn and love, it's only on the mercy, love side.
But as a child is completely rebellious, it's totally on the justice side and in a large
family reflecting back on childhood, you know, sometimes you wonder if you had the same parents
because the children veered from one side to the other.
It's exactly the same in society.
Some people live the whole of their lives without ever have seen the inside of a courtroom
or a jail, they just know they're there.
And there are other people who spend most of their lives there, they've lived their lives
at the justice end of society and they've not lived their lives at the love end.
Well it's exactly the same with us spiritually as well, that we can decide which end of the
spectrum we want, we being the human race.
And when the human race throws God out and goes into sin and everything, we've all
veered towards justice.
When we repent and we choose to live God's way and choose His wisdom and we've turned
towards mercy, I'm giving you that example so you can explain to people it's our decision
as to whether we get chastisement or not, it's totally our decision because God responds
to what we're actually doing because we're free, okay.
So we're going to be reading here that sin draws justice but if you just look at the
little way that I've reflected on it, you'll see how logical it is, okay.
As I was in my usual state, my sweet Jesus made himself seen all afflicted almost in
the act of meeting out justice, we would say, my book says giving course to justice, which
is not English, meeting out justice we would say.
But as though forced by creatures themselves, now you know what I mean by forced.
I prayed him to withhold discourages and he told me, my daughter, between the creator
and the creature, there is nothing but currents of love.
Why is that?
Because God is love, one John four seven, one John four seven, okay.
And also Sam one four five verse seventeen, God only ever acts out of love.
So the currents are currents of love.
Sin breaks these currents and opens a current of justice.
Just like saying, if a person commits a crime, then they then open an account with the police
and with the justice department, okay.
My justice defends the rights of my offended love and my love broken between the creator
and the creature and making its way into their midst.
It would want to reunite this broken love.
But if man did not sin, my justice would have nothing to do with the creature.
But as guilt begins, which of course starts in Genesis three with the fall of man, my
justice places itself on the way.
Do you think that I wanted to strike man?
No, no.
On the contrary, it grieves me.
It is hard for me to touch him.
Why?
Because he created us in infinite love.
But he himself forces me to do it and induces me to strike him.
Well, I'm sure you would have witnessed that a child can actually do that to a parent.
He can actually provoke you to see how far you would go as well.
You, he said to Louisa, pray that man may mend his ways.
So justice quickly reuniting the current of love will be able to withdraw.
As soon as we bring up the subject of justice, people think, oh, here we are, God of Sinai,
you know, all of this kind of stuff.
I don't know what volume it's in, but I've actually drawn a picture of all the attributes
of God inside.
I can't draw for notes, but I can read it.
And one of the things that comes out of the picture is that justice is loving and love
is just.
Justice is wise and wisdom is just.
All the attributes actually dovetail and concur with each other because we're inclined
to think that mercy sort of lets you away with murder and justice is just God letting
his anger out.
Now, that's human stuff is he's not to do with the divine.
And so he explains it somewhere.
I don't know what volume it's in, but that all the attributes like his love is wise.
It's not silly, stupid love, his love is wise and his love is just as well.
And we're not inclined to put the attributes of God together like that.
And I just want to say it so that that particular piece, which is only speaking starkly about
love and justice as opposites, that you wouldn't think that they're actually combined.
Is that okay?
So April the 13th, 1922, the triple affirmation of wanting to live in the divine will, the
soul who lives in the divine lives in the womb of the most blessed Trinity.
Therefore you're already living heaven on earth.
Louisa said, I was continuing my usual prayers and my beloved Jesus surprising me from behind
my shoulders, called me by my name, said to me, you wouldn't say telling me you'd have
to say said, okay, said to me is English and Louisa, the author of my will, do you want
to live always in my will?
She said, yes, Jesus.
And he said, but is it really true that you want to live in my will?
And Louisa said, it is really true, my love, nor would I adapt myself to live of any other
will.
And Jesus said, but you say that firmly, or is the triple affirmation, remember Peter?
Do you love me?
And it's because of that, that the church asks a priest or a nun, if they're taking vows,
do you really want to do this?
And you're asked three times, you have to affirm it three times, you know?
If you only affirm it once, they won't go ahead with the ceremony.
It's actually very interesting.
So what the Lord is looking for here is, and he's saying to us that at some stage he
will want an affirmation from you that you really, really, really want to go ahead.
Because it's fine to be enthusiastic in the beginning and to be very interested and learn
a lot and all the rest.
It was quite another matter to give the will, 100%, okay, so I want to give you two things
here from the scriptures, one is the triple yes at Sinai in Exodus 19.
The triple yes, and it's also, I don't really want to put the word in here, but just want
to hint at you the triple fiat, okay.
God has a triple fiat and he asks a triple fiat from us as well.
So the triple yes of Sinai is in Exodus 19, do you really want to make this covenant with
God?
And they had to affirm it three times.
And then there's the triple yes of Peter in John 21.
At Sinai it was for all the people of the Old Testament, that's Exodus 19, and for Peter
it was for all the people of the church.
It wasn't just for them sort of as individuals.
And so what the Lord is looking for is full knowledge and full consent.
You've heard that expression before, haven't you?
So we're doing our acts, we're doing our rounds, we're making our efforts and everything,
but a point will come when the Lord will say, okay, are you coming into this 100%?
And to me that's a red letter day in your life when that happens, and it will happen
very privately between yourself and him.
And there'll be no lights flashing on the outside or bells ringing or there'll be no
announcement on the telly that something big is going to happen today, something major
will happen on the earth when one person gives the complete thing.
And the Lord will say in the higher volumes that if one person gives the complete gift
the 100% he asks nothing else of that person.
Nothing else, you've given everything, isn't that incredible?
And therefore you've given God mactimum glory that a creature can actually give.
So here's Louise, and she's fairly well on the journey before this, and she's already
had three marriages with God, and here we're in Volume 14, we're now in Volume 3, so notice
he doesn't do it immediately, he gives you T.I.M.E., he knows that we need time to taste
it and to experience it and all the rest of it.
And the church has picked that up from Peter's triple affirmation that if someone has to
become a priest they've got to wait about six or seven years to give that final yes.
And if you join a community you have to wait four or five years as well before you would
give the final thing to make absolutely certain that you knew what you were doing.
And the very waiting for that is underlining the seriousness of the commitment, okay?
So Louise said, "Seeing myself confused almost fearing because she's giving a similar reaction
to Peter, why would you ask me three times and I tell you the first time?
My life, Jesus, you make me fear with these questions.
Explain yourself better, I say it firmly but always helped by you and in the strength of
your will which involves me completely in such a way that I could not do without living
in your volition.
And heaving is sigh of relief for Peter to how happy I am to hear your triple affirmation.
And heave to sigh of relief for Peter as well.
And Moses refused point blank to go ahead with the sacrifice that ratified the covenant
until the people three times publicly in the presence of God ratified it."
So this is big stuff, this is not small.
So do not fear.
These are nothing but the reassurances, the reaffirmations and the confirmations so as
to impress on you the triple seal of the will of the three divine persons.
Intellect, memory, will, the seals go in there.
That's why you're prepared with that message, okay?
You must know that one who lives in my will must rise high.
Now, high means this is the highest sanctity known to man.
It's not even known except to a few people.
It is so high as to live in the womb of the sacrosanct trinity, therefore Saint Elizabeth
of the Trinity said, "That means living heaven on earth."
Your life and ours must be one, that means heaven, because that's what heaven is.
Therefore, it is necessary, it is decorous my book says, you say that as well, it is
right that you know where you are, with whom you are and you conform to whatever we do.
And that not by force but willingly with love and with full knowledge and the full consent,
okay?
That you live there.
That's in a different image, that is that, and this has happened all over Europe, that
an ordinary person actually marries into a royal family.
So if an ordinary person marries into a royal family, they have to conform to the royal
family.
They've got to conform to their way of living, and they're not free to be that what you
call a person that's not a royal, a commoner, they're not free to be a commoner anymore
with all the freedom that goes with it.
Actually there's quite a lot of restrictions going with being a person in the royal family.
And I think that's the only image I can think of, that we are marrying into the most blessed
trinity.
Therefore there's only one will, there's only one opinion, there's only one way.
Would you imagine a midget telling God how to do things, and yet we do, and we're even
smaller than a midget, he told Louise that she was an atom, okay?
So, so now he's going to talk about us as images, okay, icons, image.
Now do you know what our divine life is?
We enjoy ourselves, not amused, we enjoy ourselves very much in issuing from us new images of
ourselves.
So if you want to know what God is like, the glory of God is man fully alive, okay?
God gave us an image of himself on the earth, and it's very interesting that in the commandments
he forbade us to make an image of him, why, because he's made an image of him in us, but
not us in a depraved state.
We are in continuous act of forming our images, of course that's Genesis 1, 27, isn't it?
We are in the continuous act of forming our images so much so that heaven and earth are
filled with our images.
Their shadows flow everywhere, the sun is our image, and the light is merely a shadow
of ours, okay, which covers the earth.
The heavens are our image which extend everywhere and carry the shadow of our own immensity.
Man is our image who carries our power, wisdom, and love, look at that.
Power is the father, wisdom the son, and love the Holy Spirit, okay?
I want to give you a few scriptures for those images.
Romans 8, 29, we're all to become images of the son.
One Corinthians 15, 49, and I gave you Genesis 1, 27, okay?
So man is our image, so if we don't show the wisdom, the power, wisdom, and love, we're
not actually manifesting who it is who's dwelling within us.
So we do nothing other than continuously produce our images which resemble us.
Now one must live in our will, living in our womb, one who must live in our will, living
in our womb, must form many other copies of ourselves together with us.
You're not allowed to do it on your own, you've got to reproduce the image.
Look at that, isn't it very important?
He's telling us we have to bring other people in.
She must be with us in our work.
She must let copies and shadows of us come out of ourselves, filling the whole earth
in heaven.
That's why it's so important for us to form the classes and teach other people and let
the things spread and spread and spread, okay?
So now in creating the first man, we formed him with our hands and breathing over him
that's Genesis 2, 7.
We gave him life.
Once we made the first, all the others take origin from the first.
He keeps on saying in these writings, we do everything with one person and all the others
come out of that.
So Adam was the one that starts the whole of the human race.
Blessed mother was the one that brought the whole of redemption and Louisa, the one who
brought all the divine will people, okay?
So once we made the first, all the others take origin from the first and our copies
of the first, our power flowing through all the generations reproduces copies of him.
Now since we constitute you, first born daughter of our will, it's necessary that you live
with us in order to form the first copy of the soul who lives in the divine will.
So that as she lives in us, she may receive our attitude and may learn with our power
to operate according to our way.
So if he succeeds in getting Louisa at the level he wants, all others can follow, okay?
Since we've made of you the first copy of a soul who lives in the divine will, more copies
will follow.
It's fascinating, isn't it?
So then he tells us in the final paragraph here that it's a long road.
The road of our will is extremely long, it embraces eternity.
And while it seems that one has navigated the road, much remains to do and to receive from
us in order to learn our ways and to form the first copy of the soul who lives in our
will.
This is the greatest work that we must do, therefore we must give you much and it's
necessary to dispose you much so that you may receive.
This is the reason for my repeated questions, do you love me, do you love me, do you remember
the three?
The three affirmations.
It is to dispose you, to enlarge you, to elevate you in order to accomplish my designs.
Now notice the three things, excuse me, when Louisa said yes, I do want to live in your
divine will to dispose you, yes, the second time to enlarge you, third time to elevate
you.
So each response, he's doing something with us.
In order to accomplish my designs, I care so much about it that I would leave everything
aside to reach my purpose.
Now why does he say that?
Because even getting one person to this level, he has achieved so much for the human race.
Why?
Because this person is going to be repairing, substituting for the whole human race, going
to be loving and honoring God and glorifying God for the whole human race.
So something major has happened to the human race.
Can you imagine what's happening with all of us trying to do it?
It's really, I don't think we could have any idea how pleased the Lord is with it, okay?
So April the 17th, 1922, the divine will becomes actor of everything within the soul and constitutes
her queen of everything, okay?
Continuing in my usual state, I found myself outside of myself and I found my sweet Jesus,
my life and my all, innumerable suns of light were coming out of him and surrounded him.
I flew into the midst of that light and throwing myself into his arms, I clasped him very tightly
telling him, finally I found you, I'm not going to leave you anymore.
Now tell me somebody who said that to him, at least with her gesture, Easter day, Mary
of Magdalene, John 21, okay, that's John 21.
She threw herself at his feet and grasped his feet, you're not going anywhere, I found
you after all this.
But you also have the Song of Songs, chapter 3, verse 4, where the bride had lost in inverted
commas, the bridegroom, eventually found him, she did what Mary of Magdalene did, or I should
say Mary of Magdalene did what the bride did, okay, and grasped his feet.
You make me wait so long, Louisa said, and I remain without life without you, but I cannot
be without life, and therefore I will not leave you anymore, and I squeezed him so more tightly
for fear that he might escape, and Jesus is though enjoying my squeezes told me my daughter
do not fear, I don't leave you either, he's been telling her that ad nauseam, hasn't he?
So you know the reference ad nauseam, don't you, Joshua 1, 5, see some of the references
you should know of by heart now, because you get them so often, okay, if you cannot be without
me, neither can I be without you, in other words love has met love, so they fuse, and
to make you certain that I don't leave you, I want to chain you with my own light, okay,
so the next paragraph is all about chaining us in light, okay.
So Louisa said, I remain so immersed and interwoven within the light of Jesus that it seemed
to me that I would no longer find the way out, now that's an introduction to what you're
going to meet in the higher volumes, where she gets a sense of the divine will as being
utterly immense and infinite, and she can go in but there's no way out at that point,
and that's the function of the triple affirmation, are you coming in, because if you come in
you're coming into an immensity that you'll not be able to go out of, because you're going
into the immensity that everybody else only goes into in death, do you know what I mean?
Louisa said how happy I felt and how many things I understood in that light, beside
that put Sam 36, 26, I've written down here, be sure, I'm not sure about the birth, I'm
26 anyway, but it says in your light we see light, okay, I lack the words to express myself,
I just remember that he said to me, "Daughter of my will, this light that you see is nothing
other than my will," now I've been saying that from the beginning, "The light is the
divine will," okay, and if you go back and read this over again, reading divine will
instead of light, you get this much easier, okay, so this light is nothing other than
my will, which wants to consume your will in order to give you the shape of our image,
now notice consume your will has to be given completely so that yours is subsumed into
the divine, so to give you the shape of our image, that is of the three divine persons
in such a way that transforming you completely into ourselves, we will leave our volition
in you as a divine actor, that means that the moment you let this happen, all your acts
are divine acts, you don't have to be asking, okay, you leave us as the divine actor which
matches us in everything we do, so our images will come out from ourselves, and our will
acting within you will take as many of them from you, now you know that each act is a
divine life anyway, don't you, okay, so the purpose of creation will be fulfilled, so
Adam failed and the Lord is restarting with Louisa, so he's going to talk to us now in
the next one about the divine image restored, the echo of our volition will be the echo
of our own volition possessed by you, the exchanges will be mutual, love will be reciprocal,
this is the way God intended it with Adam, we will be in full harmony and the creature
will disappear within her creator, now do you see this is the total surrender, the nothing
goes into the all, okay, this is the total surrender, then nothing else will be lacking
to our joy, to our happiness for which we deliver creation, that let us make man in
our own image and likeness will have had its effect, our will alone as actor within the
creature will give completion to everything and the creation will bring us the divine purpose
and we will receive it in our womb as our work just as we deliver it, so on earth as
it is in heaven, okay, so here you have the our father being fulfilled but the human will
must be subsumed into the divine so that the divine can actually take over and therefore
in this person if the divine will is the actor, the one who is doing everything then you look
at that person you should be able to see God if your eyes were open, most of us don't have
eyes like that do we, and then he said if you cannot be without me it is the echo of
my love that resounds in your heart, so it's the calls of the divine and unable to be without
me it reverberates in you and you shaken look for the one who loves you so much and
I seeing that you are searching for me feel the echo of your love within me and I feel
drawn to send you a new current of love so that you may look for me even more, so it's
not going to be less painful for her it's going to be more painful until finally the
drop of water is thrown into the wine, okay, and Louisa said I am my love sometimes as
much as I look for you you don't come and therefore now that I have found you I will
not leave you anymore I will no longer go back to my bed I cannot, what's this she wants
to go to heaven you see, you see if you taste this level of contact with God there's nothing
back on the earth I mean even at the level we're at I mean I've said to a number of people
if you got the call today would you even look back, you know I'm a million miles away from
where Louisa was at but even at the level I met wherever that is you wouldn't give it
a second thought if he said come out here you bet absolutely and that's only having
tasted the little bit that we've tasted for Louisa how she managed to live on the earth
is amazing to me I no longer go back to my bed she said I cannot I can understand it
you made me way too long and I feared that if I go back you will repeat your privations
and I squeezed him more tightly repeating I won't leave you anymore I won't leave you
anymore and Jesus although he enjoyed my squeezes said my beloved daughter you are right that
you cannot be without me without your life but what are we going to do with my will I
love this I love it he just knows exactly how to get around things and that's your two
Corinthians 5 1 to 10 I want to go and be with the Lord but the Lord wants me to do this
mission so I have to stay here okay what are we going to do with my will it's my will
that wants you to return to bed do not fear I won't leave you I will leave the current
of the light of my will between you and me so here he's telling her very very clearly the
divine will will be deposited in you that's it okay so there's no possibility of us separating
I will leave the current of the light of my will between you and me and whenever you want
me you will touch the current of light of my volition and upon its wings that's the wings
of this light of the divine will I will immediately be with you therefore go back oh dear because
you see on the earth you have to have the pain and the suffering and the merits to go with
it but for nothing other than to allow my will to accomplish its designs if poor Louise
and you she had to do 36 volumes before she'd be released I think she would have gone mad
but in the same sense you know after Peter said his yes three times if Peter knew that
he was going to have to function in Rome in that cesspool of Rome as it was at the time
he wouldn't have said yes he would have said I go back home and go back to my fishing that's
why God can only tell you things bit by bit as you grow when you have the strength and
you have he has expanded you and he has disposed you more and all that we can only take it
bit by bit that's why I call it the jigsaw puzzle it's fascinating to me so therefore
go back but for nothing other than to allow my will to accomplish its designs and the
course it wants to make within you I myself will accompany you to give you the strength
to go back but oh goodness of Jesus it seemed that if he did not have my consent he himself
would not feel like making me go back this is this is the delicacy of the thing she has
to go back because she has this big mission which she cannot grasp which is perfectly
understandable it's only much much later in these volumes that she has any grasp of the
mission that is actually giving to her but at the same time he wants you to do it voluntarily
and I mean the delicacy of that position is amazing isn't it and he would not feel like
making me go back to see God won't violate your free will and as soon as I said Jesus
do what you want I found myself but you got her back instantly to change your mind there's
where you put your not my will but then be done now the whole day I felt surrounded by
light so it's the first stage is very difficult for her so he gives her this very very strong
experience and whenever I wanted him I touched that light and he would come the following
day he carried me outside of myself and made me see all created things and not only was
Jesus their creator and dominator but from him also came the life of the preservation
of all things his creator and preserver of all things because that's the divine will
the current of the created creative power was in continuous relations with them and if
it were missing all things would resolve into nothing then my sweet Jesus told me to the
daughter of my will I want to give supremacy over everything now she's just seeing that
he has supremacy over everything and then he says I want to give it to her why is that
it's because there's only one will between them so his will would be operating through
her anyway I want to give supremacy over everything my dominion and hers must be one so if I'm
the king she must be queen okay and if I gave you knowledge of everything it's because
I want that you not only know my dominions but that you dominate with me and concur in
the preservation of all created things so she's being asked to do something that is
really divine now at the end of the song of songs this wonderful toing and froing that
goes on between the bride and the bridegroom in the end she says come let us work in your
vineyards and he says yes that's where we have to go the love between us must be fruitful
for others so you have to go and work in the vineyards so if he's going to be king she
has to be queen she has she has to work in the vineyards and working in the vineyards
of course is the reparation and the acts and the rounds and all the rest of it so just
as my will extends from me overall so I wanted to extend from you overall because the divine
will isn't it then he made me notice a point of the world from from which black smoke was
coming out and he said see over there are statesmen who wanted to side the lots of kingdoms
this is 1922 so he's showing her political leaders who want to carve up Europe and the
rest of the world around 1922 they were plotting that okay and I find it very interesting they
want to decide the lots of the kingdoms but they do it without me that's the important
bit and where I'm not present there cannot be light and if there's no light we won't
see doubly mistakes made because in the early part of the 20th century they were carving
up Africa and all the rest of it okay and just to give one example they have nothing but
the smoke of their passions which blinds them more therefore they will come up with
nothing good they will come up with something but nothing good it will only serve them to
embit her one another and cause grave or consequences which is another war poor peoples led by
blind and self-interested men you'd have to put self-interested there oh and I forgot
there the text about the blind leading the blind and I'll just write down blind leading
the blind they only thought of it this minute sorry I don't remember the reference and poor
people's led by blind and self-interested men you see if they were disinterested they'd
be right so it's self-interested these men will be pointed to as the laughing stock of
history now it's early in the the 20th century and the three stooges were Hitler, Stalin and
Mussolini they were called the three stooges by someone famous but now there were other
people as well wanting to carve up the geography books they will be the laughing stock of history
good only at bringing ruin and confusion and those three that I've mentioned brought nothing
but ruin and commute now there were lots of others as well you can write the full list
if you want but let us withdraw let us leave them at their own mercy because if people
are cruel they're cruel to everybody including themselves that they may know what it means
to do things without me any disappeared and I found myself inside of myself here she's
getting at the beginning of that paragraph you need to put Amos 3 7 Amos 3 7 the Lord
never does anything without showing it to the prophets first okay so we'll do April the
21st 1922 the effects of prayer in the most holy will of God do I need to tell you put
a VIP on that one everything that I have written and that I write is only to obey and much more
for fear that my Jesus being displeased may find a pretext to deprive me of him he alone
knows how much it costs me so I spent one day without Jesus just a few shadows of him or
God what pain I was saying to myself how soon he broke his promise of not leaving me now
he's inside of her as you know he doesn't accept that she wants something much more visible
oh eternal holy eternal volition bring me my highest good my all the pain I felt was
such that I felt hoppy and fussy and in this state I tried to fuse myself I love the I
tried to fuse myself and his holy volition in the meantime he came showing himself as
crying bitterly and with his heart cut to pieces in seeing him crying I put my huffiness
aside that's a good one and hugging him and drying his tears I said to him what is it
Jesus why do you cry tell me what have they done to you and he said am I daughter they
want to challenge me they are preparing for me an awful challenge it's very interesting
now and it's from the leaders okay my sorrow is such that I feel my heart being cut to pieces
how just it is that my justice poor itself out against the creatures therefore coming
to my will together with me let us rise between heaven and earth and adore together the supreme
majesty let us bless it give it homage for all so that heaven and earth may be filled
with adoration's homages blessing and all may receive its effect what do you think that
could have happened that Jesus would have said was a terrible challenge to him yeah they
you have the infiltration of the church by communism putting atheists into the church
do you know what I mean so that's the the one thing I can think of yeah because it was
going to it was going to be such a horrendous crisis for the church yeah okay I see only
thing I can think of because that was it that was what was going on at the time and so
Louisa said I spent the morning praying together with Jesus it's not lovely but oh surprise
as we prayed now you can say one was the word there was one word between us and that
the word was the same okay it was only one in other words there weren't two prayers there
was one prayer there wasn't two wills there was one will there wasn't two requests there
was one request it's just that that's very bad English but the divine volition diffused
it all over created things and its mark remained on all of them now you're seeing the effect
of acts in the divine will it brought it to heaven and not only did the blessed receive
its mark we would say the effects of the act but it was we'd have to say that cause of
a new beatitude for them the cause of a new beatitude for them it ascended down below
into the earth and even into purgatory and all and all received its effects so there's
the the act in the divine will actually affecting everybody but who can say how it was to pray
with Jesus and all the effects that it produced so she says something very important here
at the last paragraph then after we prayed together he told me my daughter have you seen
what it means to pray in my will this paragraph is one of the ones you need to really take
out because it'll answer questions people will ask you do you know what I mean just
as there is no point at which my volition does not exist it circulates in everything
and in everyone it is life actor and spectator of everything in the same way the act on in
my volition become life actors and spectators of everything even of the very joy be attitude
and happiness of the saints everywhere they bring light and the balsamic and celestial
air with unleashes joys and happiness therefore never depart from my will heaven and earth
that wait you to receive new joy and you splendor now heaven and earth that wait you is Romans
eight nineteen waiting for the new sons of God to show themselves who will have this
incredible effect so here you you're being told that they the acts in the divine will
affect everybody in heaven earth and purgatory it's fantastic isn't it I know you've heard
it before but every time I hear it is new I don't know for you yeah it's all that it's
the same to me as if I was hearing it the first time yeah that's why I never get tired
hearing it so April the 25th 1922 I have a VIP on this one as well thousands of angels
are the guardians and custodians of acts done in the divine will this is this is brilliant
so continuing my usual state I felt all immersed in the divine volition and my sweet Jesus told
me my daughter just as the sun does not leave the plant but caresses it with light fertilizes
it we would say with its heat until it produces flowers and fruits and then jealous it makes
them mature it keeps them with its light and when the farmer picks it to make it its food
only then will it leave the fruit this is the same with the act done in my will now notice
that the sun is compared to the power of God's love working in us that's actually what that
paragraph is about it's the same with the act done in my will my love my jealousy towards
these are the act done in the divine will is such that grace caresses them my love conceives
them my love fertilizes them and my love matures them I placed thousands of angels as custodians
of one single act done in my will does he prize it oh absolutely in fact since these acts
done in my will are seeds in order that my will may be done on earth as it is in heaven
everyone is jealous of these acts their Jew is my breath is not wonderful their shadow
is my light the angels remain enraptured by them because the angels you can't do acts
in the divine will like we do because whatever they do it doesn't carry the merits that we
have so they they look at us astounded that we have this privilege the angels remain enraptured
by them and reverent they adore them because in these acts they see the eternal will which
deserves all of their adoration only when I find souls who picking them as divine fruits
make of them food for their own souls that is somebody that the act we do in the divine
will is affecting everybody in heaven on earth and in purgatory and he said I only leave
it when somebody actually takes it and uses it for themselves just like the fruit so they
they've taken the apple and they've eaten it or they've taken the banana and they've
eaten it he said because then the work of producing that thing is now complete it has
given food so he said only then does the action stop or the fecundity or we'd say fertility
and multiplicity of these acts the creature herself who does them cannot count them that's
a wonderful piece there about acts isn't it and the next paragraph is that the acts in
the divine will put you in communication with everything so if you want to teach acts here's
an excellent one okay and I'm giving you these little notes every now and then because you
will be teaching them okay then I was thinking to myself how is it possible that these acts
are so great my books as be which is not English and why do even angels remain enraptured and
Jesus clasping me more tightly in his arms added my daughter these acts are so great that
as the soul keeps doing them there is nothing either in heaven or on earth in which she does
not take part isn't that unbelievable she remains in communication with all created things all
the good the effects the value of the heavens the sun the stars the water the fire etc are
not only in continuous relations with her they are her own things what is yours is mine because
it's a divine act it's not fantastic she harmonizes with the whole of creation and the whole of creation
harmonizes with her and therefore she becomes the person mentioned in Romans 8 19 first of all
it's Louisa because she entered fully into the divine will and then as each one of us enter into
this we become the people that Paul spoke about that the whole of creation was waiting for these
sons of God to show up because that was going to bring renewal to the whole earth okay and so
the next paragraph is even more astounding the heading I have here is souls in the divine will
become the support of their God can you imagine souls in the divine will become the support of
their God so why then because those who live in my will are the depositors the preservers the
supporters and the defenders of my will is that something else the depository first of all he
can place his divine will in you the reservers you will actually keep the divine will there you
will support and defend the divine will in all your acts they foresee what I want and without my
commanding they execute what I want and there's something about divine will actually you need to
really take on board because when we're doing all these readings and everything all of us are
giving different responses we're not carbon copies of each other okay and the Lord says that without
him giving any of us a command we are actually responding to what he wants to accomplish from
different angles that's why I keep on saying everybody has to be spontaneous not doing the same
thing just the day the spontaneous thing that comes out of your own being and he said everything
that he wants will be done I find that I find that fascinating okay and it is without commanding
in other words he hasn't laid down a law that this is what you got to say and comprehending our
understanding the greatness and the sanctity of my will they keep it and they defend it
jealously so we all appreciate as much as we possibly can the greatness of the privilege of
being able to do divine will act so we do defend it and look after it how could anyone not remain
in raptured in seeing these souls who form the support of their god but this time it's you and
me it's fascinating isn't it yeah it's no idea I've only one comment for that well as a writer
is in the margin and they are the support of their god by virtue of is by the power of the
prodigy of the divine will who can ever defend my rights if not one who lives in my will who can
ever really love me if not one who can love me with divine love understood okay with a love
of disinterest similar to my love if not one who lives in my will I feel stronger in these souls
but strong of my own strength because all the actions are done on the divine level I am like a
king surrounded by faithful ministers who feel stronger more glorious more sustained in the midst
of his faithful ones and by himself alone it's not fantastic if he remains alone he regrets not
having his ministers because he has no one with whom to pour himself out and to whom to entrust a
lot of his kingdom that's the way I am and whoever who could ever be more faithful to me than one
who lives in my will I feel my will being duplicated and therefore I feel more glorious I pour myself
out in them and I trust them now that is the most astounding statement that god could trust
a creature of his i think it's a good place to stop